can you walk us through what happened
with the buzz aldrin incident you were
you were trying to do a uh you were
setting them up you were speaking to a
few different people kind of walk us
through what happened on that day
well let me let me go back a little bit
to the to the progress here even though
we're kind of doing this out of order uh
basically when bill casey first
suggested that i do
a film about this right which is when i
was 24 years old it was about 30 years
ago i turned it down because i saw the
shadows intersecting i saw the soviets
were more advanced i saw two of the
three guys don't give interviews
uh the administrator resigns they
reported twitter two guys that didn't
give the interviews i'm just curious
well michael collins and neil armstrong
they only make very brief anniversary
remarks every you know you know 10th
anniversary or something like that buzz
aldrin does you know all the talking for
them and i find that kind of odd
if there were you know three people who
you know won a great sporting event and
and two of the three refused to ever
talk about it i would find that kind of
strange and if the administrator of that
sporting event resigned a few you know
uh weeks before the first mission or
first game of that series and there was
you know all this suggestion of fraud i
would find that suspicious i mean that
photograph of 90 degree shadows from
objects five feet apart it's electrical
lighting there's no way to duplicate
that in sunlight it's impossible
it means those pictures were taken here
on earth so but i'm telling you 30 years
ago
it scared me because i personally i have
kind of a a relentless personality and i
also love puzzles we were talking about
games before we got started i love games
and puzzles and i said to myself patrick
i said look if anyone could figure out
whether he went to the moon or not it
would probably be me
and i said you know it looks like
there's a good possibility that the
missions were fraudulent
and so i turned down the project i said
i want to have a wife and a family
someday why should i risk my life
for other people's mistakes so i turned
down the project and then another client
of mine a christian client
said hey i'll get one of your scripts uh
mr filmmaker to a famous hollywood
producer if you do me a favor i'm like
sure they said read the bible
so i started reading the bible june 5th
1989 the day the man stood in front of
the tanks in china
and it was a one-year bible divided into
365 reads and over the next five years i
read the bible five times from cover to
cover
and after that i realized you know there
is a god
there is good and evil
there is a judgment for how we live our
life
and i said to myself
if they didn't go to the moon
that's more profound than if they'd
actually gone think about this patrick
let's say they could go to the moon that
would have a certain level of
significance to mankind but if they
couldn't go they lied about it they
murdered people to keep it a secret
that's more profound
than if they'd actually gone and i said
if they didn't go this is important for
mankind to know otherwise we won't grow
we won't learn from our mistakes we'll
be stuck in this corrupted world
so i called up bill i said i changed my
mind i decided to make the film anyway
well let me tell you these films cost
one million dollars and we were financed
by a board member of an aerospace
company who builds rockets from nasa he
knows from an engineering point of view
that we didn't go to the moon and he
said it was his patriotic duty to
finance these films to expose this fraud
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]